Petite surprise que nous réserve apple :
ils viennent de lancer sur leur site web
un nouvel iPhone SE. On l'attendait
depuis longtemps je vous en parlais depuis
très longtemps. C'est
un smartphone qui avait beaucoup marché.
C'était un tout petit format avec un écran
de 4 pouces. Un format qui manquait un
peu et que beaucoup de personnes aimaient
et souhaitaient voir revenir.
Apple arrive avec un iPhone SE 2
sortie directement sur leur site.
Je vais vous le présenter. Vous expliquer
sa fiche technique. Es-il
intéressant? Est-il fait
pour vous ? Tout est noté ici.
On va débuter en parlant
de son poids.
Il pèse 148 grammes.
Il est léger et petit.
Il est plus grand que l'iphone SE de
première génération.
Il fait quelques centimètres de plus
car l'écran est un petit peu plus
grand. Mais le design
reste très similaire. On retrouve l'ADN de l'iphone SE
qui avait cartonné. Il y a un
mélange de matériaux : un châssis en
aluminium et un dos en verre. Il est disponible en
3 couleurs : noir, blanc et rouge.
Le fameux de Product Red.
Il a un écran de 4,7 pouces. C'est une dalle IPS, du LCD.
C'est l'écran Retina HD. Sa résolution
est de 1334x750 pixels à 326 pixels
par pouce.
Il vient se positionner entre l'iPhone SE de première génération
et l'iPhone Xr. Il n'a pas de résolution Full HD
mais Apple maîtrise la qualité de ses écrans
même sur une résolution plus faible.
Ils sont bien calibrés.
Nous verrons cela lors
du test. Je vous invite à vous abonner
si ce n'est pas déjà fait. Il a un écran
True Tone avec une luminosité maximale
de 625 nits. Il ne semble pas être très lumineux.
Il a la même luminosité que l'iPhone Xr.
Son écran n'est pas le plus grand.
L'expérience multimédia ne sera pas la meilleure.
Par contre Apple a mis des haut-parleurs stéréo
pour ajouter de l'immersion
lorsque vous allez jouer parce que vous pouvez jouer
sur cet écran de 4,7 pouces.
Il a la dernière puce d'Apple : A13 Bionic.
C'est la même que celle de l'iPhone 11 Pro Max.
Elle fonctionne très bien dans de nombreux cas dont
la réalité augmentée. Elle est idéale pour la gestion de l'autonomie.
Sur l'iPhone SE vous aviez la puce A9
donc d'ancienne génération.
Il est disponible avec 64, 128 ou 256Go
de stockage.
Il se recharge avec un câble Lightning
Apple annonce la même autonomie
que l'iPhone 8.
Nous verrons cela dans mon test.
Il a un chargeur de 18 watts inclus qui permet de charger de 0 à 50 % en 30 minutes.
Il est compatible avec de la recharge sans fil.
Il faut acheter le chargeur séparément.
Il fonctionne avec iOS 13.
Il a un seul capteur photo de 12Mpx
à l'arrière avec une ouverture de f/1.8
une stabilisation optique.
Il a un zoom numérique X5
La caméra avant a 7Mpx et ouvre à f/2.2.
L'iphone SE de première génération avait une caméra
de 1,2Mpx.
Il a la technologie Smart HDR.
Le mode portrait logiciel pour les deux caméras
avec le mode studio,
naturel, mono, éclairage de scène ...
Vous pouvez faire de la vidéo en 4K jusqu'à 60fps. Enregistrer en stéréo.
Il n'y a pas Face ID mais Touch ID.
Autre nouveauté : il a une certification IP67.
Il dispose du toucher haptic. Du WI-FI 6.
Du bluetooth 5.0.
Il a un slot nano-SIM et vous pouvez utiliser une E-SIM.
Les pré-commandes ouvriront le 17 avril à 14H.
Il coûte en version 64Go 489 euros.
Vous aurez un iPhone neuf avec la dernière puce A13 Bionic
qui fonctionne très bien à moins de 500€.
Il a effectivement un petit écran de 4,7 pouces mais
c'est un produit qui s'adresse aux
personnes qui veulent un format compact
extrêmement performant, très endurant.
Vous l'achèterez si vous voulez l'essentiel d'Apple :
puissance, performance, iOS.
Vous ferez quelques photos mais ce ne sera pas l'usage principal.
Vous aurez un petit écran. Un iPhone peu encombrant,
léger. Il apporte un produit manquant chez Apple.
C'est un produit réactualisé.
Il trouve facilement sa place dans la gamme.
En version 128Go il coûte 539€ et
avec 256Go il coûte 659€.
Vous vous connecterez rapidement à la maison avec le WI-FI 6.
Très facilement à vos AirPods avec le
Bluetooth 5.0.
L'autonomie devrait être bonne.
La performance est bonne également.
La partie photo n'est pas complète
mais ce sera déjà très bien.
Je suis heureux de vous le présenter aujourd'hui.
Est-ce que vous l'aimez ?
Abonnez-vous car mon test sortira très bientôt.
Vous saurez tout très bientôt.
A demain pour parler de tech.
Ciao.